philadelphia it turned out carson wentz
wasn't good enough nor was doug peterson
nor was
a lot of guys who had been on the roster
since they won the super bowl three
years ago
there is a long article in the athletic
and when i say long
it's long and i apologize that i just
don't have it in me to read
all of these long ass articles i'm sorry
i still believe you should get a t-shirt
if you can prove
that you read one of these things start
to finish and i would submit to you that
not many t-shirts would have to be made
because i doubt that even the members of
the media who shout from on high what a
great thing it is that this long article
was written they don't read all of it
either shireen
sorry just a what rant that i have to
can i admit i didn't read all of it
how can anyone at a certain point here's
what happens you start reading with
every intent
with every intent i'm gonna read it i'm
gonna read it i'm gonna read it
and then after about five or six
paragraphs it's scroll scroll scroll
scroll look for something that jumps off
the page isn't that what we all do
isn't that what we do so why write a
long ass article like that what am i
missing
uh i like to write them i it you just
don't have enough time to read them mike
i agree with you you don't have time
enough to read them you don't
nobody does yeah i i mean it's in this
day and age the way things are moving
especially if you're in the business you
don't have time to shut your workday
down
for 45 minutes and study a long article
i appreciate the effort
i'm not being well i am being critical
i'm being critical of the whole
the whole mindset like like it's oh this
is a good thing it's not a good thing
anymore
maybe it was a good thing years ago when
they actually printed things on paper
and people waited to get sports
illustrated
and it was actually more than a
five-page pamphlet the thing that came
to your house
maybe it was a good thing then we had
nothing better to do we didn't have
phones
right we had four channels on the tv but
but it takes too much time
no one is savoring the poetry
of sportswriting anymore i'm sorry
they're not sharing
it's a different world it's
transactional it's informational tell me
what you've learned
tell me what you've learned and what
we've learned is shocker
there's dysfunction in philadelphia and
there is some
some compelling explanation of the way
that doug peterson
allegedly reportedly was treated by the
team micromanaged every tuesday got
called into the principal's office and
had to explain himself away even when
they beat the packers
on thursday night in the 2019 season
when it was the only home loss the
packers had for a long time in the
matlab floor regime
had to answer a bunch of questions about
that why aren't you passing more and
it's that tension
between analytics and football analytics
and football one of the things in there
that validates one of my beliefs about
the current
state of the nfl sharing the owners
and the analytics people have a tighter
bond
than the owners and the football people
and the analytics people
have a hell of a lot more sway than we
realize
over the owner the one who ultimately
makes the big decisions about where the
football program is going
yeah i agree with you mike and and i
think we've seen that we've seen it with
with a bunch of organizations i don't
know if every organization is like that
but a bunch of them have gone that way
no question
and you look even when that article
talked about the 2017
season if the eagles had gotten off to a
slow start they were already preparing
to replace doug peterson and of course
they got off to a 10-1 start
and ended up winning the super bowl that
year so so that didn't happen
but it's amazing to me how this
organization has fallen apart
so quickly i mean 2017 right they're
super bowl champions
they end this this long run of not
having a championship
team over 50 years and they win a
championship and all of a sudden
this whole thing has come tumbling down
and it so much feels like they're in
rebuild mold
they're 22 and 25 and one uh since that
super bowl
and i just don't know how it went so
wrong so fast but it certainly did i
know carson wentz
played a part in that but it just sounds
like this was a team in dysfunction
even before they won the super bowl mic
yeah and they got a lot to do to turn it
around and they're a team that i
mentioned on friday in an item at pft
still keep an eye on them as a potential
desean
watson destination at some point they're
the team that gave mike vick
his second chance after his legal issues
of 2007 through 2009.
i'm not saying now i'm not saying soon
i'm saying whenever
wherever the desean watson career
continues do not rule out
the philadelphia eagles unless they have
somebody better than deshaun watson
at the time he becomes available
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports